[Music]  Jennifer Lopez touched down in the  Dominican Republic late last week for a  special weekend concert featuring ex  Marc Anthony at Casa de Campo Resort the  former couple crushed it on stage but  the focus was more so on J Lo's current  coupling with Alex Rodriguez  I'm feeling pretty cool a rod who is of  Dominican descent joined his lady in the  Caribbean videos have surfaced on social  media from J Lo's performance  after-party and they show the couple  getting down on the dance floor looking  like they're having the time of their  lives the party took place in the 10,000  dollar luxury villa the couple is  cheering at the resort it features six  bedrooms and a private pool the couple  is also giving back while in the dr  they're expected to make some charity  stops this week pretty serious for just  a couple months of dating  [Music]